The Fallout from Jake Lloyd's appearance
as Anakin Skywalker in Star Wars Episode
1 The Phantom Menace is well documented
but it stands as one of the swiftest and
most unpleasant Falls from Grace
experienced by any actor just 10 years
old at the time of the film's release in
1999 Lloyd's performance seemed to
shoulder the brunt of negative reaction
to the film despite this Mark Hamill
defended the young actor by explaining
to vulture he did exactly what George
Lucas wanted him to do online Venom from
disappointed Star Wars devotees combined
with Relentless off- camera bullying by
other kids made Lloyd's life in his
words a living hell he retired from
acting in his pre-teens and struggled
with mental health issues in 2015 he was
taken to a psychiatric facility after
leading police officers in a Pursuit
that resulted in a slew of charges his
mother Lisa Lloyd issued a statement to
geek news now in 2018 that her son was
living closer to his family who were
quote all working hard to help him